[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
John Smoltz joins us now John who's
played golf with Michael Jordan probably
lost money to Michael Jordan have you
ever taken money from Michael Jordan on
the uh Golf Course
oh yeah yeah yeah this uh
greatest competitor of all time uh what
you don't do is you don't talk trash you
just play possum you don't try to be
anything other than just go about your
business and at the end of the day
hopefully you beat them but if you talk
trash if you get them riled up similar
to Tiger You're Gonna Lose
uh have you seen that happen
yeah oh yeah yeah funny story first time
I ever played him he was still playing
in the big league all right I was still
playing in the big leagues he was still
playing in the NBA we played in Chicago
on a 38 degree day and I had no resume I
had no resume we're the only ones on the
course and he had a putt for I don't
know 25 feet perverty on the last hole
if he makes it and I miss my seven
footer he wins and uh he stands up over
the Putt and like he lines it up and he
steps back and he goes He rattles off
his resume
as if this is no big deal you know won
three MVPs whatever it was at the time
is impressive and then he made the putt
and I'm like well now what do I do I
stand over my Putt and I go we lost 100
games two years in a row
I had nothing to go to luckily I made my
pot but I realized just even the time
spent with him over the years and tiger
there's just such a different level and
you you get intimidated just hearing uh
when somebody can kind of quote or say
all that their resume kind of speaks to
all right help me understand tonight you
got Japan against the United States I
would think this is the match-up that
you want if you're Fox
um tell us what to look forward to
tonight
well you're you're seeing one of the
most complete teams in team Japan from
the first person on the roster to show
hey watani
um I'm Amazed by their discipline the
way they go about their game they all
wear the same suits the same shirt and
the same tie like everything is about
unisons and the fact that everything
they do is has a reason and a structure
behind it no different than that game
last night they were able to come back
because they didn't waver or play or get
outside their game so you're gonna see
one through nine have a complete
Approach at the play unlike anything or
any roster that we put together because
the style of baseball is different in
the US we have more swing and Miss more
Homer type guys and our lineup is stud
lineup but that's what you're going to
see you're going to see uh Darvish who
the kind of a good thing for the Team
USA that they know that pitcher even as
good as he is it helps their lineup be
familiar with the kind of stuff they're
going to see and then I got this sneaky
suspicion that may be late in the game
if team Japan is up you may see shohei
Otani close it out and would it be
something more than theater yeah that if
shohei Otani with two outs and a runner
on is facing Mike Trout for the chance
to win the WBC either way would be
pretty incredible if it actually happens
help us understand uh Roki suzaki the 21
year old how good is he and uh what's
the destination or time destination for
to him to end up in uh Major League
Baseball
yeah it's interesting everyone's saying
anywhere between three and six years
based on the protocols that that they
have over in Japan he is dynamic I mean
they're talking about ahead of otania
and his pitching and we all know what
otani's doing as a pitcher his ability
to throw a fastball free and easy and
repeat his mechanics and that slip
finger he didn't even throw his slider a
curveball and I'm I'm not blown away by
too many hyped up moments I've had the
Strasbourg moment I had
and he lived up to that hype that night
and struck out 14 and of course his
career has been unfortunately undone by
injuries but this kid is special and so
there were 64 Scouts now that number
doesn't make sense to me there's 30
teams
do I really need two from every team but
there were 64 people watching him pitch
last night but why three to six years
John
the the posting for certain teams I've
got I've learned to understand is six
years before you can post unless the
request is granted by the player and or
the club and then it's a lot less the
player can make there's all kinds of
different rules for the posting you know
uh shohei Otani and Darvish had their
posting was so great that the Japanese
built a basically new brand new stadium
over there because of the posting that
comes to them so they understand
eventually he's going to go it it really
is an individual choice and of course
Club control over the time frame how big
is the WBC and can you see where we're
not waiting for years
well you know there's so much
conversation around what the Team USA
hasn't had on their roster in the past
and it's starting to be filled up a
little bit better there's some
restrictions of course that the
conversation always goes like this look
if your mindset you come to spring
training you think you're going to get
hurt you're going to get hurt but we
have players get hurt in spring training
all the time and we don't really notice
it but if somebody gets hurt in the WBC
we Bang the Drum and it's got to be
canceled so there's got to be this
understanding from the clubs and USA
baseball Federation that the more stars
we have the better it is and those
countries are starting to Showcase their
stars and get into a point where now
that's why the excitement is the way it
is and it's played out with Mike Trout
playing and he had guarantee of from
everything I've heard he's going to
spread the word wherever he goes to any
player in the big leagues saying you
want to be part of this that's going to
help the future of WBC gain more and
more attraction because this has been an
epic one this has been one that
everyone's been waiting for for a long
time have fun tonight John great to talk
to you
my pleasure go Spartans that's John
Smoltz Hall of Famer